[Music]
when people think of Vladimir Putin they
think of capital P power and that's
exactly the impression creates whether
it's physical power firing different
weapons riding in various James
bond-esque modes of transportation or
tossing hapless opponents or political
power ruling his own country with an
iron fist crushing his political
opposition or most recently being
accused of meddling in foreign elections
for his own benefit this is how bladder
your Putin went from a poor tough kid
and lemon grad to a KGB spy to the very
symbol of modern Russia Vladimir
Vladimirovich Putin was born in 1952 in
Leningrad which is now st. Petersburg
his father was a factory foreman and his
mother a homemaker
it is widely said that Putin's public
facing tough-guy persona can be traced
back and getting into fights when he was
younger which paved the way for him to
take up judo after getting a law degree
from Leningrad State University
Putin joined the KGB Foreign
Intelligence Service he spent 16 years
in the KGB when Putin returned to Russia
we began his political career he went to
work for a little some child who is the
mayor of st. Petersburg at Leonid
worship I always fall over real thrived
in subject administration because he was
sort of considered pretty efficient
pretty official at the time he was very
royal for some child so loyal and
efficient that he was noticed by me also
squirrels circle and those people soon
brought Putin over to Moscow to work in
Yelling's administration where he
quickly climbed the political ladder and
of course she was promoted to prime
minister of Russia
that's Dmitri I am currently director of
the Carnegie Moscow center around this
time
yeltsin and the people around him the
so-called family decided that poop would
become Yeltsin successor and then this
happened
the apartment bombings were carried out
three Russian cities killing 293 people
and injuring more than a thousand Putin
immediately accused Chechen separatists
for the bombings and followed it up with
action she was pretty good we're having
a very successful military campaign
against the terrorists it worked after
that he became an heir apparent in the
eyes of the Russian people
three months later Yeltsin resigned and
on his way out
a famous exchange he was getting into
the car in the Kremlin and the last
words that he addressed before getting
into his car was taken care of Russia so
Putin took over as president three
months after that won his first election
but just because Putin won the
presidency and didn't mean he had all
the power this is Michael McFaul Mao was
a US ambassador from 2012 to 2014 in the
1990s there was a fire sale of all the
things worth owning in Russia and
certain people yelling or did better
than others in that fire sale sometimes
called privatization and those people
tended to be well connected with the
Yeltsin regime and they weren't too in
friends but they probably
miscalculations thinking that they could
easily find a retain person became
impossible almost all the scars from
that very moment that was what happened
the oligarchs that's when Putin gave the
oligarchs a choice whose way some of
those people from the 90s managed to
figure out a new way of dealing with
Putin and have survived or prison others
could not find common vision and so they
lost their assets credit card scheme
once was Russia's richest person worth
fifteen billion dollars when he ran
afoul of President Vladimir Putin and
spent a decade in prison the domestic
power consolidated Putin focused on
restoring Russians of global influence
which was the guy who believes in the
expansionist Russian state at Georgia
and Ukraine but all the other Soviet
republics
little in Soviet Union fell apart he
still believes that their traditional
Russian satellites a world of his
strategy is about keeping them in orbit
but equal to the lines a good care of
Russia that's how he understands and
used annexation and invasion as well as
oil gas and trade to keep former Soviet
republic and russia orbit and 2008
Putin's two terms were up and he decided
to step down as president Dmitry
Medvedev stepped in as president and
Putin went back to Prime Minister but
really never left power keep pretty much
contained in running the country and it
was also a figurehead
there was actually a period of
cooperation between Russia in the US
that benefited both countries during
that units presidency because let be
honest did not have the same negative
attitude towards the last as Putin did
but when Putin came back to run for a
third term and the lead-up to the 2012
election is why we believe that both
presidential and parliamentary elections
were rigged Russians took to the streets
Putin blamed the protests squarely on
America and more specifically Secretary
of State Hillary Clinton he believes
that she had sent his words a signal to
demonstrators still Putin won by a huge
margin and set about crushing the
protest movement immediately upon his
return to the Kremlin over the next few
years
Russia's economy tumbled Putin annex
Crimea leading to sanctions the price of
oil fell drastically the ruble hit a new
low and America played down Russia's
influence with Obama calling Russia a
regional policy despite all that Putin's
approval rating remained sky-high and
then an opportunity for payback
I think I'd get brittle Ong very well
with Vladimir Putin in 2016 there was
one candidate who called Emerson very
smart
Trump exhibited tolerance towards
Putin's actions annexing Crimea and
similar views on NATO and sanctions
Secretary Clinton wouldn't support any
of those shoes even though Putin denies
any wrongdoing
resonation
the US has accused Russia of being
behind the leaking of 20,000 Democratic
National Committee emails which many say
helps Trump beat Hillary Clinton in the
presidential election which leaves us
here with the possibility of a President
Putin until 2024 positioning Russia to
be the world power
he always imagined it should be
you